[...]
[Patient is draped and prepped for surgery.]
[Local anesthesia is administered.]
[...]
[Scalpels and other instruments are shown.]
[A machine for nitrous oxide and ether is brought over to the hospital bed and a mask placed over the patient's face.]
[Components are adjusted.]
[...]
[The patient's chest is opened up and surgery commences.]
[Blood vessels are clamped and additional incisions made as surgery continues.]
[...]
[Portions of the ribs are removed.]
[Surgeons begin to sew up the patient and close the incision.]
[...]
[The sewn-up incision is shown and gauze is applied.]
[Another chest surgery is shown.]
[...]
[The exposed lung inflates and deflates.]
[Rib resection is shown.]
[...]
[The surgeon points to the subclavian artery.]
[The incision is closed.]